0 1% là sur ullrich a énormément
augmenté qu'est ce qu'il faut pour avoir
du pouvoir d'achat partagé pour la
programmation bien la seule manière de
faire c'est une activité privée
dynamique il permet de distribuer des
revenus suffisants pour faire face au
coût de la vie et la réalité c'est que
sur ce plan rien n'a été fait vous
faites de la dette comme ça et quand
vous imprimer des billets comme ça vous
fléchés de fait sur les gens qui
détiennent le capital
donc ça arrive de fait sur les marchés
par exemple l'action ça fait monter les
titres mais ça ne m'apporte rien dans
notre assiette
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
à la une des militants adéquistes
racisme prise à partie lors du meeting
d'eric zemmour candidat à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 ils étaient
une dizaine installé au fond de la salle
l'association a diffusé une vidéo sur
twitter montrant des participants projet
moore en train de les frapper ils ont
été évacués de la salle à à villepinte
on va retrouver sur place notre reporter
dans un instant autre meeting
aujourd'hui à signaler celui de jean-luc
mélenchon à la défense
[Musique]
demain qu'on fait de défense sanitaire
très attendus pour évaluer la cinquième
vague de covin en france avec à la clé
peut être de nouvelles restrictions à la
proche des fêtes de fin d'année le pays
qui dépassent la barre de 50 mille
contamination en 24 heures un bilan de
samedi fait face à à l'apparition du
nouveau variant au micro
[Musique]
le pape françois appelé dimanche à
mettre fin au frh de civilisation dans
un dribble vibrant discours au camp de
migrants de lesbos un message cinq ans
après sa première visite cette île
grecque emblématiques de la crise
migratoire c'était donc deuxième jour de
sa visite en grèce
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt franc semble un
dimanche marquées par plusieurs meetings
de campagne à commencer par celui d'eric
zemmour candidat à la présidentielle et
non biance surchauffe et c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire on va retrouver
notre reporter à nadège abderrazak à
villepinte en seine-saint-denis c'est là
que le polémiste à rassembler ses
partisans
certains d'entre eux ont pris ont été
prises à partie par un des militants des
militants donc des sceaux est racisme
qui n'était pas à l'extérieur mais bien
à l'intérieur notons qu à des
rassemblements se sont déroulés devant
le parc des expositions bilan 46
interpellations
on retrouve l'adage abderrazak
bonsoir un adage alors le premier
meeting de campagne d'eric zemmour a
donc été marquée par plusieurs incidents
absolument samantha on s'attendait à ce
que des tensions soient plus fortes en
extérieur et pas à l'intérieur du parc
des expositions c'est tout l'inversé qui
s'est passé il ya eu plus de grabuge à
l'intérieur de ce parc des expositions
alors elle avait l'événement le plus
marquant reste eh bien ces images de
violences qui ont opposé des partisans
d'eric zemmour à des militants de
l'association sos racisme la situation a
dégénéré lorsque ces militants ont
présenté des t-shirts avec l'inscription
non au racisme milon a rapidement été
agressée violente et à part des
militants pro eric zemmour alors des
chaises ont été balancés un plusieurs
d'entre eux ont été blessés puis la
presse a également été prise à partir
lors de ce premier meeting d'eric
zemmour nos confrères de tmc de
l'émission quotidien ils ont été prises
à partie par la foule qui a rapidement
scandé plusieurs slogans hostiles à
quotidiens ont donc on a pu entendre
quotidien dehors quotidien as collabos
encore tout le monde déteste jeunes tout
le monde déteste au quotidien alors
c'est une équipe qui a dû être exfiltré
par le service d'ordre du désormais
candidat à l'élection présidentielle ils
ont pu revenir à l'intérieur d'eux la
salle pourrait bien continuer leur
travail et puis l'arrivée un d'eric
zemmour a également été quelque peu
perturbée puisque le polémiste a été
agrippé par la nuque par un homme alors
il a été rapidement maîtrisé et
exfiltrés également par le service
d'ordre donc un premier meeting d'eric
zemmour quelque peu perturbé qui a été
et bien
l'objet de plusieurs incidents majeurs
aujourd'hui ja villepinte
merci beaucoup à vous nada jaber asac
pour toutes ces précisions
et les autres détracteurs d'eric zemmour
se sont donné rendez vous en début
d'après-midi à barbès leur cortège a
rallié à la villette il était de 1200
selon la préfecture de police près de
dix mille selon les organisateurs ils
ont défilé dans le calme contre les
idées du polémiste à deux personnes ont
été arrêtées on va écouter quelques
réactions
on manifeste aujourd'hui par rapport aux
idées qui sont en train de se propager
au delà de zemmour 1 seymour et les
autres et qui sont des idées
effectivement raciste c'est la première
des raisons racistes et xénophobes
sexistes
voilà parce qu'on entend beaucoup de
choses si là dessus et moi
personnellement je viens d'une famille
qui a connu
les persécutions et donc je suis là
parce que je suis atterré
j'aurais jamais pensé en tant que ça
joue bah en fait c'est complètement
vendée mesurer ce qui se passe c'est que
le vt de se réunir ensemble et d'être
dans un groupe qui contre ça va ça
redonne un peu la force aussi et ça
permettront de recul je soutienne ou
guaino tout le monde ne pense pas comme
ça est ok oui il ya des gens qui
trouvent que c'est complètement faux pas
dont le nom fut bois et que ça n'a aucun
sens et c'est pas normal on peut être
c'est insupportable cette hégémonie
qu'il a dans les médias moi c'est ça qui
il peut se présenter je veux dire mais
jusque je ne comprends pas c'est cette
hégémonie dans les médias pourquoi au
nom de quoi il est il est partout au nom
de quoi et pour contrer le polémiste
eric zemmour le candidat à la
présidentielle de la france insoumise a
choisi le même jour pour organiser son
premier meeting de campagne jean luc
mélenchon à rassembler ses partisans du
côté de la défense hélas pris la parole
pendant plus d'une heure et a présenté
les grandes lignes de son programme on
l'écouté nous venons montrer au pays
pour lui redonner du courage alors qu'il
est plongé dans l'obscurité de débats
absurdes où l'on voudrait qu'il ce
compte là l'autre pour des affaires de
religion ou de couleur de peau nous
venons dire est programmée une grande
fois de plus dont la france n'est pas
l'extrême droite
la france c'est la sécurité sociale
c'est la santé publique c'est
l'émancipation
c'est l'école c'est la recherche et le
partage
demain conseil de défense sanitaire pour
faire le point sur la cinquième vague et
l'émergence du variant omicron sur le
sol français dix millions de français
ont reçu une dose de rappel le
gouvernement qui attend qui entend
convaincre les français de se faire
vacciner massivement seule solution pour
éviter une saturation des hôpitaux on
voit cela avec adrien fondu
les fêtes de fin d'année seront elles
encore soumise à des restrictions à
moins de trois semaines du réveillon de
noël c'est une question que le
gouvernement se pose est une inquiétude
justifiée par les chiffres de l'épidémie
la cinquième vague monte vite cinquante
mille diagnostic par jour ces derniers
jours c'est beaucoup en france
actuellement c'est un malade qui est
admis en réanimation toutes les dix
minutes on est bien au-delà de la
quatrième vague et on est en train de
rejoindre le pic de la troisième si rien
ne change nous aurions un pic sanitaire
qui pourrait intervenir à la fin du mois
de janvier cette cinquième vague si
ressemblante est pourtant différente des
précédentes delta présent depuis
plusieurs mois c'est maintenant le
variant omicron qui préoccupe les
autorités sanitaires alors que les cas
de contamination augmente et même si la
vaccination progresse avec déjà 10
millions de dose de rappel administrés à
l'hôpital de strasbourg le plan blanc a
été réactivé la crainte également cette
période j'ai vraiment vraiment pas envie
de la revivre on appréhende vraiment
qu'on l'ait l'écoville dix arrivant
après l'autre début de semaine j'étais
au service y en avait trois fins de
semaine y en a huit et on voit que ça
arrive de plus en plus et on a
l'impression qu'on va effectivement
revit cette période qui a été
complètement horrible ingérable et et on
ne sait pas vers quoi parfois revoir
encore des gens parce qu'ils sont pas
vaccinés c'est vraiment désespérant
c'est désespérant pour les médecins
désespérant peau pour toute l'équipe et
puis pour nous sur le plan humain c'est
vraiment très triste et puis on voit des
gens qui après une fois qu'on les a
guéri ni tralala j'aurais dû me faire
vacciner c'est vraiment j'ai pris les
mots manquent au bout d'un moment
strasbourg le plus grand marché de noël
en france ou avenue des champs elysées à
paris la magie a déjà commencé à opérer
en coulisses à l'occasion d'un conseil
de défense sanitaire prévue ce lundi il
sera question de freiner l'épidémie sans
enrayer la dynamique festive
[Rires]
on en vient à la l'épidémie en belgique
et avec cette manifestation dans les
rues de bruxelles aujourd'hui contre le
renforcement à des restrictions
sanitaires une manifestation baptisée
marche pour la liberté acte 2 une
manifestation qui entendait de
capitaliser sur le succès de la première
elle aurait rassemblé huit mille
personnes selon les forces de l'ordre
quelques tensions ont été identifiés la
police anti-émeute a été déployée l'a
fait usage de canons à eau
je pense que chaque personne le choix de
se faire vacciner c'est son propre choix
et c'est la liberté à mon avis
mais pour notre liberté donc on sait ça
braqué moi je travaille dans l'espoir
donc à partir du mois de janvier je vais
être mis au chômage et licencié
franchement c'est honteux qu'on en
arrive là c'est max et là j'ai trouvé
que c'est pas vraiment au top par contre
la dictature solitaire bien évidemment
au delà de mon métier la manifestation
pour mon métier c'était hier je suis pas
allé il ya pour mon métier tu allais
pour mes libertés en tant qu'être humain
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui que ça
lève pour une mobilisation alors que les
restrictions s'alourdissent dans le pays
à la proche de noël fermeture des cafés
des restaurants à 23 heures
rassemblement en intérieur limité port
du masque obligatoire pour les écoliers
on voit cela avec cyrielle bourriche
al'approche des vacances de noël la
belgique prend des mesures drastiques
les écoles maternelles et primaires vont
fermer leurs portes avec une semaine
d'avancé annonce ce vendredi du premier
ministre belge alexander de croo dans
les écoles le port du masque est
obligatoire pour les enfants dès l'âge
de 6 ans selon les autorités ces mesures
doivent soulager les hôpitaux belges
actuellement en forte tension se
trouvera en nombre de lits occupés par
aco vite en a malheureusement aussi un
impact sur d'autres personnes trop
souvent nous voyons que des personnes
qui doivent avoir d'autres interventions
la ration une intervention cardiaque on
leur dit que il n'ya pas de place et qui
doivent qui doivent attendre cette
situation c'est une situation qui n'est
pas tenable il ya trop de circulation
difficiles c'est vraiment trop et donc
il faut diminuer la circulation du virus
est là où il ya encore un moteur qui
tourne et il faut essayer d'arrêter ce
moteur est hélas c'est chez les jeunes
enfants ce n'est pas de leur faute ce
n'est pas la faute des écoles ou des
activités de jeunesse
c'est parce que cette crise la
population n'est pas protégé par un
vaccin pour la troisième semaine
consécutive le gouvernement belge a donc
choisi de serrer la vis à partir de ce
lundi les événements en intérieur seront
limités à 200 personnes et le masque
sera obligatoire une règle applicable
notamment dans les cinémas et les salles
de concert pour les bars et restaurants
les restrictions restent inchangés
fermeture des établissements à 23 heures
et nombre de clients limité à 6 par
table de nombreux centres de vaccination
ont rouvert leurs portes pour
administrer des doses de rappel
comprends juste pas les gens qui se font
pas vacciner ce que je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment avoir cet effet de
masse de se vacciner
pour pouvoir s'en sortir plus vite donc
aujourd'hui comprend pas les gens qui
sont pas vaccinés je pense que le
gouvernement fait ce qui peut et ferrand
le maximum pour que les choses aillent
mieux donc
on suit et les mesures on suit les
indications afin que les choses aillent
pour le mieux il n'y a pas de solution
magique le vaccin protège map à 100% et
les anti pacs va rester à la maison
pas inviter des comptages et
lui même pour éviter surcharge des
hôpitaux pour éviter de contaminer des
autres présents à ce jour 76 % de la
population belge a déjà reçu au moins
une dose de vaccin le mot d'ordre des
autorités reste le même vacciné et
réduire le plus possible les contacts en
2020 les fêtes de fin d'année était
limitée avec un système de bulles social
de cinq personnes maximum cette année le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité renouveler
l'expérience malgré les recommandations
des experts
c'est toute l'europe qui fait face à la
nouvelle vague épidémique le continent
est frappé de plein fouet ici et là on
alourdit donc quand les restrictions
pour freiner la chaîne de contamination
et certains plaident même pour une
vaccination des adultes obligatoire de
quoi faire bondir est les plus
réfractaires les manifestations se sont
multipliées ces derniers temps à
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense vraiment que nous ne devrions
jamais avoir à montrer nos papiers peu
importe où nous allons je crois à
l'autonomie personnelle
[Musique]
notre liberté est en danger parce que le
pass sanitaire devient obligatoire pour
tous nous sommes épiés dans nos propres
environnements un environnement où nous
devrions être libres nous devrions être
libres de nous déplacer partout nous
allons partout non voulons aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
dans l'actualité le pape françois est
arrivé ce matin sur l'île de lesbos il a
visité le camp de mav rooney qui
habitent près de 2200 demandeurs d'asile
le souverain pontife appel à mettra fin
à un naufrage de civilisation et
s'inquiètent que la méditerranée soit
devenue un cimetière théo combes et yves
ollivier biche
il a fait de la thématique migratoire
son principal leitmotiv qui t'attend
c'est certains dirigeants de l'union
européenne
le pape françois était en visite sur
l'île de lesbos ce dimanche
accueilli par de nombreux exilés du camp
de mme havre envie ni qui ont organisé
un accueil des plus chaleureux
[Musique]
derrière l'ambiance festive le ton se
voulait plus grave pour le souverain
pontife qui a une nouvelle fois rappelé
aux dirigeants européens leur devoir de
secourir ceux qui prennent la mer pour
risque d'y laisser leur vie
s'est lamenté ne permettons pas que la
marée nostrum se transforme en une
désolante marc est morte où mme que ce
lieu de rencontres deviennent le théâtre
de conflits ne permettons pas que cette
mère de souvenirs se transforme en une
mère d'oubli frères et soeurs je vous en
prie arrêtons ce naufrage de
civilisation une nouvelle sortie
quelques jours après avoir dénoncé le
mur de l'aisne dresser face aux migrants
devant les principales figures
politiques grecs le saint père a
néanmoins rappelé que le pays avait fait
d'importants efforts en matière
migratoire croit pas et c'est une plante
à la cognée ce pays dix musées à
l'accueil a reçu sur certains de ses
cils un nombre de frères et soeurs
nigrum plus élevé que celui des
habitants
estimant temps assis leur dit qu elle
indique aussi lorsqu'ils ressentent
encore la conscience de la crise et
connaît les fatick est née la crise
économique un discours qui intervient
alors que s'intensifient les tensions
migratoires en europe de la méditerranée
en passant par la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne sans oublier
la mort d'une vingtaine de migrants
noyés dans la manche une accélération
des problèmes liés à l'immigration qui
pousse certains pays comme l'italie a
demandé plus de solidarité entre les
membres de l'union européenne
pensons aussi aux migrants qui
débarquent souvent sur nos côtes et dont
les origines sont souvent très éloignés
de la mer
nous ne pouvons pas contrôler les
mouvements migratoires qui ont donné
lieu cette année à 63000 arrivée soit
six fois plus que 19 nous avons besoin
d'un implication accrue des pays
européens
en méditerranée
de là son discours humaniste le chef de
l'église catholique a rencontré des
familles de réfugiés choisi au hasard
puis repris son chemin direction athènes
pour une messe devant quelques 2500
fidèles
visiblement rien ne peut prouver la
prétendue collusion entre la russie et
donald trump le rapport stills avait
pourtant essayé et force est de
constater que désormais il n'y a plus
rien le fameux informateur sur lequel
tout reposait a été arrêté par le fbi en
cause ses mensonges entre temps ce
dossier style a été repris plusieurs
fois par des médias des médias qui
manifestement ne recoupe pas les
informations allez précision avec thomas
bonus
au mois de novembre
igor dantchenko était arrêtée accusée
d'avoir menti au fbi ya un problème il
était en fait l'une des seules sources
sur lesquelles se sont appuyés les
médias pour évoquer les liens supposés
entre donald trump et le kremlin c'est
donc avec ces informations douteuses que
s'est constitué le dossier style du nom
d'un ancien agent du renseignement
britannique le document publié en
janvier 2017 par le site buzzfeed une
publication qui fait grand bruit à
l'époque le kremlin aurait des
informations compromettantes sur le
président américain qui lui permettrait
de le faire chanter et ainsi de
s'assurer de son soutien
une méthode qui a porté ses fruits pour
ea était d'exploiter les obsessions
personnelles et la perversion sexuelle
de trump dans le but d'obtenir un
compromis sur lui selon source ed qui
étaient présentes le comportement
pervers de trump à moscou a notamment
consisté à réserver la suite
présidentielle du ritz carlton hotel où
il savait que barack et michelle obama
qu'il détestait avait logé lors d'un de
leur voyage officiel en russie et à
souiller le lit où il avait dormi en
faisant appel à des prostituées pour
qu'elle réalise des golden shower devant
lui
une théorie qui s'est depuis effondrée
comme un château de cartes suite à
l'inculpation dit gordon tchenko n'ayant
plus le choix que d'assumer ses erreurs
le washington post a pris la mesure
extrêmement rare de corriger des
articles sur cette affaire notamment sur
ses allégations concernant cet hôtel
moscovite
l'inculpation assurée par durable le 4
novembre suggère mais n'infirme pas
explicitement que dan tchenko aurait pu
obtenir son information sur cette
rencontre à l'hôtel non pas par milian
mais d'un membre du parti démocrate
ayant des liens de longue date avec
hillary clinton tout en saluant la
transparence de ce mea culpa on est tout
de même en droit de s'interroger sur la
responsabilité de ces médias rappelons
quand même que certains auteurs de ces
articles corrigé depuis avait reçu le
prix pulitzer en 2018 pour leur travail
sur ce fameux russia gates et puis quel
impact auront ces corrections en
comparaison au battage médiatique
gigantesques provoquées pendant des mois
par ses allégations reprises partout y
compris dans les médias français quant
aux leçons à tirer de ce fait ce qu il
ya deux écoles il ya d'abord ceux qui
reconnaissent un peu tard mais c'est
toujours ça une erreur collective de la
part d'une profession certainement
biaisé par ses opinions politiques la
situation est aussi devenu compliqué
parce que certains reporters nez mais
simplement pas ou ne faisait pas
confiance à monsieur trump ou ne
voulaient pas apparaître comme étant son
côté il a insulté les journalistes de
charlatans tout en cherchant leurs
applaudissements dans un monde parfait
les journalistes devraient traiter les
gens qu'il n'apprécie pas de la même
façon que ce qu'ils apprécient mais ce
n'est pas un monde parfait et puis il ya
ceux qui s'accrochent aux branches
estimant que le dégonflement du dossier
style n'a pour but que de masquer les
véritables éléments qui attesterait de
cette collusion en tout cas cette
affaire style s'est révélé être le
dernier fiasco en date d'une certaine
presse américaine qui peut sembler
davantage préoccupé par son agenda
politique que par sa volonté d'informer
ses lecteurs pourquoi jeter encore
davantage de discrédit sur des médias
des gens on croit des sondages peu
avantageux moins de 40% des américains
disent aujourd'hui faire confiance aux
médias de masse
en gambie le sortant adama barro serait
largement en tête de la présidentielle
le pays est appelé à voter hier et le
dépouillement toujours en cours livre
progressivement un verdict favorable à
l'actuel président adama barro qui est
en tête sur près de 40 des 53
circonscriptions que compte le pays
devant son opposant historique ousseynou
dargaud ses opposants contestent les
résultats
provisoires
on prend la direction de l'afghanistan
la situation sanitaire est inquiétant
depuis des années là bas face à ce
constat le gouvernement français a
implanté à kaboul un hôpital
l'établissement offrant des soins aux
plus démunis qui fait face à de lourdes
obstacles financiers reportage sur place
de notre envoyé spécial antoine gayraud
bienvenue à l'institut médical français
de la mère et de l'enfant ou tout
simplement l'hôpital français de kaboul
un établissement de soins fondée en 2006
avec le concours du gouvernement
français et de l'omg la chaîne de
l'espoir depuis quinze ans on y soigne
gratuitement les plus pauvres et on y
pratique des prix raisonnables pour les
autres mais cela ne suffit pas à couvrir
toutes les dépenses
nous facturons aussi les patients et
quand le déficit est trop important il
est couvert par la chaîne de l'espoir
l'aga khan development network et le
gouvernement français ainsi nos
partenaires viennent combler les écarts
que nous avons dans le domaine financier
donc c'est eux qui nous finance sont des
fans de cet hôpital est ouvert à tous il
suffit simplement de prendre un ticket à
l'accueil
et ensuite se présenter à la réception
qui vous dirigera vers le bon service
l'hôpital dispose d'une maternité n'est
pas seulement on y réalise toutes sortes
d'examens dont certains n'ont pas
d'équivalent dans le pays nous regardons
ces échantillons afin de diagnostiquer
le cancer et d'autres pathologies
auxquels les patients sont confrontés
des pays en faillite
certains patients font des heures de
route juste pour une consultation dans
cet hôpital à swindon des
achats nous venons de la province de
koundouz dans le nord
nous avons consulté là-bas le traitement
n'a rien donné nous avons donc décidé de
venir ici
malgré cela il y encore de nombreux
afghans qui n'osent pas se faire soigner
mostafa
hénaff many to go to hell
comme chez la plupart des nôtres n'ont
pas assez d'argent pour aller à
l'hôpital pour consulter un docteur et
ne peuvent pas s'acheter de médicaments
quand il faut opérer cela coûte de
l'argent et ils refusent même s'ils en
ont besoin ils refusent parce que leur
situation économique est difficile
cette délicieuse du tonnerre bad
économique sécurisé à l'afp m
décidemment ce temps
la situation sanitaire dans le pays est
presque catastrophique
elle est en stagnation ou ne voit aucune
amélioration avant d'apposer la marque à
l'aide du sol qui dit doit les enfants
ne mangent pas à leur faim un as de
graves problèmes avec les adultes et
beaucoup de malades ne peuvent pas être
traitées dans le pays ils doivent partir
à l'étranger pour être soigné le seul
hôpital qui est aujourd'hui le meilleur
à kaboul c'est l'institut médical
français pour la mère et l'enfant si
hastac d'un réel ou dans les autres
hôpitaux il y à une grave pénurie de
médicaments et de personnel médical
[Musique]
au delà de toutes ces difficultés
propres au contexte afghan comme partout
ailleurs dans le monde il ya la pandémie
de kobe 19 qui vient s'ajouter d'accueil
situation la situation avec le comité
très mauvaise les gens sont malades et
les services dans le pays ne sont pas
entièrement fonctionnel ils sont
incapables de fournir des soins aux
patients atteints du col vide et à
l'hôpital toutes les précautions qui
s'imposent pour éviter la propagation du
co lead ne sont pas prises ce que je
pense c'est que les gens sont à l'heure
actuelle concentrer sur d'autres
priorités plutôt que sur le communal
plus important pour eux de nourrir leurs
enfants que de s'informer sur les gens
celui conclu davantage de ça
dans un pays où le système de santé est
en lambeaux et où la situation sanitaire
se dégrade de jour en jour l'hôpital
français de kaboul fait figure
d'exception mais son avenir reste
fragile entre les exigences du nouveau
pouvoir et les obstacles financiers et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans une trentaine de minutes rester
avec nous
et
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure de gens dont deux singes
le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu es descendu
sa joie sur europe 1 a révélé nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du mam où je
me trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis
un beau matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve que les
troupes comme ce quelque chose de bien
les grands filaments je suis étonnée je
râle je dirais que ce sont des collègues
russes qui sont venus tripatouiller le
fond de ma recherche et puis à force de
tirer dessus comme rien ne venait je me
suis aperçu que j'étais sur le dos
turnhout
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose alors gens font-ils
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
quel effet le quinquennat des manades
macro aura-t-il eu sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages français on m'a
toujours sous-évalué le rythme de
l'inflation et donc on peut vous chante
lecteurs le pouvoir d'achat a augmenté
la réalité c'est qu'il abaissait le
pouvoir d'achat
8d 0 1% là sur le riche a énormément
augmenté est ce qu'il faut pour avoir du
pouvoir d'achat partagé pour la
programmation bien la seule manière de
faire c'est une activité privée
dynamique il permet de distribuer des
revenus suffisants pour faire face au
coût de la vie et la réalité c'est que
sur ce plan rien n'a été fait vous
faites de la dette comme ça et quand
vous imprimer des billets comme ça vous
fléchés de fait sur les gens qui
détiennent le capital
donc ça arrive de fait sur les marchés
par exemple l'action ça fait monter les
titres mais ça ne m'apporte rien dans
votre assiette
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
rendez vous politique hebdomadaire
au sommaire la crise migratoire une
semaine après le naufrage causant la
mort de 27 migrants dans la manche la
question brûlante de la crise migratoire
revient sur la table il y a quelques
semaines une autre crise aux frontières
de la biélorussie et de la pologne a
montré l'impuissance de l'europe face
aux défis migratoires
quelle position russe elle doit elle
adopter l'europe at-elle les moyens de
lutter contre les passeurs et le trafic
migratoire le royaume uni doit-il
reprendre le contrôle de sa frontière
c'est le débat de la semaine alexis
poulin et jacques de guilbaut vous
éclaire ensuite sur l'actualité
politique du monde d'après mais d'abord
lumière sur le polémiste slash candidat
eric zemmour ce mardi l'éditorialiste a
déclaré sa candidature après un
déplacement chahuté à marseille qui
ternit son image
l'engouement semble être quelque peu
retombé alors eric zemmour est il
vraiment aux présidentiables quels défis
attendent le nouveau candidat comment sa
candidature est-elle perçue chez ses
adversaires est dans son camp c'est
l'habitude des éditos avec